you know what a Harlequin is the
Harlequins role is to serve the
Harlequin we see in birds of prey is
nothing like the Harley Quinn from
Suicide Squad sure she still has her
unique quirks and whatnot but the new
Harley is way more concerned with
calling the shots than following the
Joker's orders and that's all thanks to
you Margot Robbie you brought something
new to your character making her way
less one-dimensional filming a
high-profile movie isn't always easy
there are tons of rules to follow but
you manage just fine
most of the time anyway the cast of
birds of prey didn't always have the
easiest time following their list of
super strict rules but that didn't stop
them from delivering an a.1 film keep
watching to find out which rule forbade
Margot Robbie from eating real egg
sandwiches while shooting the movie do
you know what that means that means he's
not just after the kid anymore he's
after all of us every birds-of-prey
actor brings something new to the table
and for Ellen J Bosco that was magic
tricks Ella is a first-time movie actor
who happens to be only 13 years old in
real life she portrays Cassandra Cain in
the movie but stepping into her
character shoes was a challenge in
itself during an interview with Good
Morning America Ella revealed that she
had to undergo extensive magic training
with magic castle magician Robby
sobieski mastering a slew of magic
tricks was crucial when it came to
playing her character who was known for
being a generally sneaky and skilled
thief the young celebrity had to master
sleight of hand movements like snagging
someone's wallet out of their pocket on
top of many other tricks
so while Ella's co-stars were working on
mastering their own characters
capabilities Ella spent months learning
the art of magic and as it turns out
magic training was the least of Ella's
worries Cassandra Kane is a street kid
she is super mushy be is when you sign
on to be a star as a beloved DC
character there's a good chance that a
sequel or two might be in the works
and since recasting such a high-profile
role could confuse viewers it's normal
for actors to be asked to prioritize
sequels failing to reprise their role
cause complications and a cast up birds
of prey is not exempt from this rule
this is Margot Robbie's second take on
the notorious villain Harley Quinn and
there's a good chance that she will
reprise her role in future DC
installments as will the rest of the
cast while on Good Morning America
Margot was asked if there was any
character she would like to bring in if
a sequel happen but instead of denying
sequel rumors as many actors do Margot
quickly answered that she would love to
see poison ivy on the screen again and
we couldn't agree more
who knows maybe uma thurman's daughter
Maya Hawke will get to take over her
mother's old role and then Gotham will
be mine for the greening
this next rule applies to the stunt
doubles who performs some of the most
outstanding stunts in birds of prey
since flawless transitions had to be
achieved stunt doubles needed to look
exactly like the characters they
portrayed this wasn't always easy
however since the stars like Margo
journey and Allah were constantly
improving their physiques throughout
rigorous workouts stunt doubles had to
be on the same diets and exercise
regimens to maintain proper body
measurements as a result jurnee smollett
bell had not one but two stunt doubles
Bethany levy and Anisha Gibbs most
surprisingly Ellijay Bosco had to have
three different stunt doubles seeing as
the teenager was constantly growing
while filming the movie Jade Kwan and
Marisa Lubov doubled as Cassandra Cain
and Lee Chesley was brought in for
reshoots but this wasn't the only
problem caused by Ella's growth spurt
keep watching to find out which rule
constantly had to be changed for the
young actor
Cyril here for me
although it's hard to believe
considering how many wicked moves the
cast performed they did most of their
stunts but to do this without getting
hurt they had to train like their career
depended on it literally
according to jurnee smollett Belle she
and her fellow actors had to train for a
total of five months before attempting
the stunts during an interview with The
View Margot Robbie talked about how she
and her fellow actors were trained for
their stunts as it turns out it was
their stunt coordinator and team 8711
who whipped them into shape in the first
place although the cast had to train
before and during the filming process
Margot revealed that she was happy that
this rule was in place in her opinion
executing stunts is the best part and
she didn't want to give that up still
that didn't make filming meet carousel
scene any easier it's no secret that
Margot Robbie wasn't a fan of her
barely-there costumes in Suicide Squad
she was made to wear and perform stunts
in the shortest shorts and DC history in
fact you might as well even call them
bathing suit bottoms
although the actor didn't say anything
about her costume while filming the
movie she opened up about how
uncomfortable it was and people listened
luckily for Margot her outfit was given
a well deserved makeover in birds of
prey sure Harley Quinn is still clad in
short shorts but they at least offered
some coverage and this time around
Harley was given tons of different
costumes during an interview with
Fandango all-access Margot revealed that
she loved every single one of Harley's
outfits and her co-stars dished about
how wonderful their costumes were - and
we're happy to hear it after all it
wouldn't have made a difference if they
disapproved of their on-screen wardrobe
because the choice just wasn't theirs to
make the cast of birds of prey had to
wear whatever they were assigned and
most of all they are not allowed to bash
their outfits in interviews at least not
until the movie comes out now did I cut
ties with mr. J I'm about to learn that
a lot of people want me to directors and
producers want their actors to bring a
new flavor to the characters they play
they encourage them to make emotional
connections while fully immersing
themselves into their on-screen
counterparts L&J Bosco's character
sports a pinky cast during the movie and
it's customary for teenagers to draw all
over their casts
so directors asked Ella to decorate
Cassandra's cast with her very own art
Ella was sent three different casts and
made to draw all over them then Ella had
to sit tight for about two hours while
fifteen exact replicas of the cast's
were made during the same interview with
Fandango All Access Ella explained that
she really enjoyed this rule because her
art was used as an overlay for her
characters cost you Ella also revealed
that she was able to take one of the
cast's home with her as memorabilia
unless we all want to die
very unpleasant death we're gonna have
to work together most of the time actors
only take critiques from producers and
directors so it's rare that they'll hang
off of their co-stars every word but
this was very much the case when it came
to margot robbie in the end Margot was
more than just a leading lady in fact
she's the one who created the concept of
birds of prey and pitched it to Warner
Bros the idea came to her while filming
Suicide Squad and she desperately wanted
to see it come to life on the big screen
Margot had invested a lot of time in
researching Harley Quinn and quickly
realized that there were tons of amazing
DC female superheroes she was keen on
creating a girl gang superhero movie and
she was right on the money
as a result Margot also produced the
film under her lucky chap entertainment
banner so she was more than just a
co-star to her fellow leading ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
actors have found out the hard way that
DC fans take their superheroes seriously
margot robbie revealed that she was
threatened by fans who didn't enjoy her
initial performance as Harley Quinn
making a happy experience slightly
unpleasant but that didn't stop her and
the rest of the cast from getting the
job done but to do this properly they
all had to do their research studying
the ins and outs of their characters
proved to be most important anyone who
wasn't a huge DC fan quickly became one
by studying their characters backstory
and jumping headfirst into the DC
Universe to accurately convey their
on-screen counterparts the cast had to
adopt their quirks any dark origins only
then could they do their character
justice
some actors chose the method acting
route
while others read every single comic
book their character ever appeared in
one of Margo's favorite things about
Harley Quinn is her childlike attitude
which is clearly showcased in the film
Harley is often seen eating handfuls of
candy and birds of prey and let's not
forget about eggs sandwiches
the cast actually had to eat the food
that was given to them on set but this
proved to be a problem for Margo who was
allergic to chicken eggs according to
the actor the egg whites have a protein
that caused her to experience intense
migraines unfortunately she didn't think
about this when writing egg sandwiches
into the script during an interview with
Fandango all-access Margo laughed about
the number of egg sandwiches that she
had to eat on set but since she's
allergic the actor had to swap chicken
eggs for duck eggs to prevent herself
from getting sick and so Margo had a
strict no chicken egg rule while
shooting the movie they give me
migraines there's a protein and chicken
egg whites that can give people
migraines and I get it hit every actor
knows that being cast in a blockbuster
film can be a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
so complaining about trivial things like
hair makeup and outfits just isn't an
option but for Ella who is just 13 years
old complaining about her outfits proved
to be necessary the costume designers
who worked on birds-of-prey had their
work cut out for them with Aleph they
had one rule to follow be adaptable
after all ella was growing so fast
designers had to constantly alter her
costumes it wasn't just her clothes
though Ella's feet were growing too
which caused her to develop some painful
blisters while shooting the movie Ella
had to have multiple fittings because
she continuously jumped sizes every
month or so
Margo recalled an instant where Ella
tried on her pair of shorts for a
reshoot only to find out that they had
transformed into Daisy Duke look-alikes
in a matter of weeks
and that's a wrap before you go tell us
who your favorite DC hero is in the
comment section below and be sure to
tell us what you thought about the girl
gang superhero movie thank you for
watching the things hit that subscribe
button for more and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up we'll see
next time